بروزه اوكرانيا نقطه الخلافيه على المسرح
الدولي خلال الحمله الانتخابيه لا يمنع من
بروز نقاط اخرى ان انتقل الكونجرس الى
ايدي الجمهوريين من التعامل مع العلاقه
المتوفره اصلا مع الصين الى التعامل مع
منظمه اوبك بلس خاصه بعد قرارها خفض
الانتاج وما صاحبه من انتقادات من الاداره
الامريكيه
لكن سيطره الجمهوريين على الكونغرس قد
تعني اطلاق الرصاصه الرحمه على جهود البيت
الابيض لاحياء الاتفاقيه النوويه مع ايران
بل من غير المستبعد ان ينضم اليهم مشارعون
ديمقراطيون صفحه المفاوضات مع طهران
لان اداره بيضا حاولت بحسن نيه العوده
ان الخطا في ايران وليس في واشنطن لهذا
لدينا جبهه موحده ضد كل من ايران وروسيا
سيطره الجمهورينا على
دبلوماسيه الرئيس لكنها لم تحرمه من
صلاحياته الدستوريه في مجال السياسه
الخارجيه بل قد تتحولوا علاقته امريكا
بالعالم الى ملاده الاخير لان اجنده
الداخليه
سيعتريها الشلل والجمود فيما تبقى من
ولايته الرئاسيه محمد العلمي الجزيره
واشنطن